I wake up the next morning notification
I see a notification on snapchat so I
opened it didn't even last a second so
this is this is an accusation has been
made from your sister towards a prophet
a Baba who doesn't the sheet I'm just
going to leave it then we're gonna go
further so I kind of investigated the
matter obviously when we watch the video
we're gonna come back and we're gonna
talk about the principles how does the
shutter I deal with this because a lot
people do with it with the emotions yeah
no I saw it I heard it it must be here
no no let's do this yet let's go and
hear the recording from the sister her
story her take on the matter and we'll
come straight back
okay so you guys will be able to hear it
okay
[Music]
[Music]
and he said to me assalamu alaikum
nakawara come Salaam brother how are you
I'm good and we exchanged all that and
then his third question was are you
married
I said no and I've got a thought of
ourselves okay hang on
it this guy's asking me are you married
is a very Islamic guy he may be
interested in a mock in a you know in a
marriage conversation you know that's
the first thing that came into my head
yes and then after la made even more
clear to me that he is interested in my
marriage talk was his next question how
old are you laughter he goes to me I use
I don't really use Instagram I used
snapchat for my personal life so do you
have snapchat I said yes I do got hardly
ever use it but here you go anyway so he
asked me on snapchat accepted him all
snapchat with only he only asked me one
question but I asked him one question
his question was have you ever been in a
relationship and I am Santa and he and
then I asked him he goes he have been in
many knocks it off was the end I said
okay now I will cook the next morning
the first thing I do when I wake up is
obviously Nakuru so check my phone
so once our own screenshot the other
person knows that you screenshot a yeah
so the next morning I wake up see this
notification or see a notification on
snapchat so I opened a and I'm like huh
have I just seen I didn't even last a
second honestly not even a second up
there so I saw hung on this is from the
duck same guy and I looked her again I
go up at home and I saw I saw my bed I'm
like you see this again but before I did
I thought you know and then message box
saying talk and I get a message saying
in
this guy cannot see this knob until you
see until he accepts you as a friend
don't stop just I was like hang on this
guy's blocked me that means so I'm sayin
um how dare you send me such a
disgusting picture look how to stay look
at the way you dress such a mechanic's
prop expose remember ah it's people like
you that are displayed disgrace to
Muslims
look at you peered at the way you dress
look at you deeds New York have you
scared of the expose and Instagram so
you want to add me on snapchat long see
good cerveteri pictures and watch you've
messed with the wrong person you just
wait the restroom again what you gonna
do now block me are you gonna come out
with some dumb excuses but then one of
my friends actually said to me so I'm
taking this matter seriously because I
then gay you like you said we don't want
people to just think that they can use
my combo hug and that look times happen
yeah we don't want to make it seem that
she was a count Kong get hacked about
the issue here is we don't want people
to use that as an excuse and say oh
that's good idea I'll do this and when I
get close out the same I can go have to
get it but when we're also negating that
accounts cannot be hugged because they
can be hugged you get it and so so we
just don't want people to think that
because there might be a legitimate case
of something that is happening and and
people can start doubting phenol yeah
your account got hacked yeah a lot of
sisters think that if they come out that
you know they're gonna be shamed and
this star so they stay silent when they
stay silent they're aggressors or these
people who are taking advantage of them
become louder if that makes sense the
victim to stay in silent but the
perpetrator becoming louder stop there
before we start our video with our Masha
inshallah I want to give you guys an
update the marital committee's are
nearly ready inshallah I will be
advising this sister in the for clip in
my marriage documentary how to suss out
somebody who's genuine and not
and who is who is there to mess around
and play around and give you heartache
and waste your time also I'll be telling
you guys how a sister came through a
brother that I know would you find that
mom as documentary for marriage and I
said okay that's really good and guess
what's happened as I was following her
and seeing stuff that she likes and you
know stuff she comments on stuff that I
found that was very grim and very
unexpected in my marriage love means
you're gonna find out exactly how that
happened though you will see for
yourself the kind of stuff I found out I
don't want any of you guys to fall into
what I did and to find the genuine true
partner inshallah
brothers and sisters we've got an
amazing amazing website coming that's
gonna make your life easy I'm going to
help every single one of you guys to get
married easily to the person you want
very soon let's watch the video
problem sisters you heard that for
yourself and very clearly the sisters
told her side of the story and I briefly
do touch up and that audio clip that
I've got in contact with a brothel yeah
I won't caught up with Rafa I found out
because the the sister put it on a story
because the first thing we need to do is
let's take you off you know let's talk
the store name just our yeah okay good
somebody comes with them someone comes
comes when accusation yes
now the Sharia has a way of dealing with
this there's a mechanism of the Sharia
yeah and this is called baba put a spot
on mean it literally means dude judicial
law so there's a due process that has to
happen yeah okay whenever an accusation
is made on another person yeah who the
snare because and everyone really
initially the Plainsman look at the
complaint and the defense and the
plaintiff you know first I almost from
Texas you are you bleeding them in jail
confess it won't be never for two
billion oh you have a man if a first can
evil rebellious person comes to you with
something for two billion you clarify
yes terrified now our position in a
court of law
is that we cannot accept the the the the
the accusation of anyone
irrespective who is yes until we look at
the and we hear the side at the other
side okay Riley okay and then obviously
there's certain mechanisms that we can
use such as witnesses or oaths or etc
etc so Quran and supportive evidences
and a ruling can be made but the point I
want to emphasize here is that it is
invalid
it is invalid for anyone to claim and to
make an
position and for it to be taken on face
value like this in fact it's a crime to
do this and in fact a person who makes a
claim upon another person the
respectable for it is can be subject of
course this within an Islamic state it's
an environment it can be subject to what
we call terror is it that is a
punishment by the the ruler or the judge
okay if a false accusation is made and
it's not supported with any cooperative
evidences hmm okay so that's very
interesting because this is a very
serious matter cause in the Sharia peace
blunder it's punishable by lashes you
know why no no it's to present yes and
that's why the sugar came down to the
area came down to protect five things
some say six the sixth thing being there
LT what of someone yes so there is a
mechanism there are please protocols and
principles in place power in place and
to protect this exactly especially with
the accusation that was made and why
didn't they believe in man assume the
best our default position you're telling
us is that first we assume the best
number one and that's the one thing that
I tried to tell the sister let's assume
the best could have been hacked anything
could have happened and that's and
that's how the first step should be and
the reason why were coming to people of
knowledge brothers and sisters is
because London is a massive thing for me
to be honest to do the video on my own I
thought to myself now because slander is
a huge thing and it has to be dealt
accordingly because people have Hazard
Lee yeah I heard this no I saw this and
they spread this information and you're
actually damaging this source more f1
yeah we're a lot more Tyler has one
whole page dedicating a certification
yes it's incumbent upon this video to go
back and you know you know why it's so
important because three years ago I did
a documentary where I went to France I
went to Paris yeah okay into these
ghettos and actually was threatened with
a girl committed suicide she threw
herself out the window because you a
video circulating of her committing zina
with a man and this rumor was fine about
and I was saying how could you make this
accusation you don't know the video why
are you talking about we live in a
technology where can be photoshopped
anything could happen freaked me from
rock like another judge for sure that
you look for that was is there any doubt
of course these people by the way you
know Herman you know something
the CCTV video footage we won't even be
admissible yes time Photoshop especially
because of this in fact this is actually
a formal crochet so back in the day 15
20 years ago whose name of this opinion
we're not for the Rockefeller you can
see your frozen books inside my heart
yeah you never be friends with me say
same except this is the mess you know
about the love pony he says his meal a
lot hello anymore Bobby her city rocky
Selim are they make a Connie he says
well la he if they only knew the
disgusting nature of my soul my inner
secrets no one would even sister them to
me anyone menu society they would shy
away from me turn away from me and they
will never be more seriously and that's
what there's add water if someone
praises simple as if someone praises you
you say to them that you know may Allah
forgive me for what you do not know
about me and may Allah make me better
than what you think of me and it's a
beautiful to other you should keep in
mind but just moving on now obviously
the reason one of the reasons were why
we're doing this video is because Janna
then they even though we should invest
with the brother we don't believe in
those him his accounts had no problem
but the issue is there are brothers out
these platforms that are doing this you
know now as brushing under the carpet
takes the responsibility of you know
okay he only just know because these are
sisters they can't turn to other
brothers yeah okay then who are they
going to turn to here and this makes
them and this issues happen before you
get it so now what do you advise those
brothers who have these platforms yeah
so one of the reasons we've done this
video is to be honest way to put the
fear in their heart and shall tell you
something for myself is wrong this
should keep me in check but if it's me
expose me well I I'm telling you if if
it's me whoever it is only if it's been
done cause I had stories of 15 sisters
came to me about 15 and yeah and it's
it's it's problem and we have to and
this should keep everybody in check
so what do you advise was wrong as you
have a platform be it nasheed be a dour
be it or on what if it may be whatever
you doing you wanna give some advice you
know maybe the for short but I mean yeah
I mean look number one and you know no
doubt you put personal bit positions and
meet oh it was due to a position digital
platform that you have okay now the
reality is is that firstly a lot I don't
what I'll last part is giving you this
suppose that every network that you have
this question we on camera so this
platform that you have number one are
you using it for good oh using it for
sure are you from the only of Allah from
the friends and helpers of Allah hope
this deen allah jalla says kun answered
a lot be from the helpers of allah o
from done sort of sharing you the help
of shape on so the reality is we have to
read the question or suppose I see
exactly where do we fit in this one
because it - very good for the confusion
or for it but for now Allah says they'll
be part in the dinner and a part in the
knot
it's as simple as that there is nothing
between ok except for us how often
eventually they will go to your night
long discussion will store anyways
whenever they would meet with one
another they will advise one another
with these words
whenever the right one another they'll
right at the bottom of their letters on
their books or soft these woods you know
the woods
I mean us Lahav city after who are slow
fallow I'll any at all that means
whomsoever rip defies his private
affairs
I lost my rectify this no whomsoever
rectify that last March I will rectify
that which is with the people whom so
ever does this and concerns himself with
the earth kara i lost from towns he
cares the dunya for you tomorrow yeah
you're right sure you know allow you
need to ask yourself this question bomb
sisters yeah it's the fooling in a nurse
losses
it's the wound a minute nurse what is a
lot you know suddenly sir that they hide
away in the shy away from the people but
they don't shy away from Allah and Allah
is with them when they spend their
nights doing things with these are lost
problems are so we really have to give
this because it's a form of the father
it's a form of hypocrisy appropriate in
our actions and you know span inevitable
are the words of the people of course we
know from the Herrera yellow Tiger I
drew that one of the first person of
three people to be thrown into the fire
the party the Mujahid the early research
of the Quran you know the mood ahead and
the end the scholar and he is supposed
to be the most blessed of Deeds yeah we
can extrapolate from this anyone who's a
platform to call for good if it means
that behind closed doors I would say
Billa he isn't doing that what she wants
against
yes and so his position was very
questionable
yeah and not sure and this this happens
both ways have to say this this thing
it's not just brothers doing this
Yani it happens both ways the onion
personally in my marriage I've I've
witnessed things left I've been asked
towards me banished so let's get this
why because it's not like a home or not
be on the men's side
absolutely females do this females even
actually message to trap public figures
on purpose hello and speak in certain
ways you know just so they can heart
troubles they are I see my life this is
done it's both one is plotting one is
put in it the other one the one the man
who's doing the maybes Unicode of
desires which is wrong still a lie still
wrong the other one is plotting and
planning you know let me taking me how
can I trap him yeah and that's why I
promise sisters in Java and also
fearless panatela imagine this was your
sister imagine some other man sending
dirty pictures to your sister your wife
your mother your daughter
well now you lose you the plot don't be
a hypocrite do not be hypocrisy you for
sure every every one of the sinners
don't think of us some perfect beings
well I anyone we asked a lot to
particular you know us is a lot
protection that we're not doing it don't
think of all the great I lead our chef
above Sofia one light if we ask of us
wanted to protect us and that's it
bothers and sisters hope you guys have
enjoyed this video there's nothing to be
enjoyed by but I hope it's been a nice
pin you've learned a lot and you deal
with the situation on the right way and
jump on it you know cuz otherwise you
hear something here yeah let's no don't
go we don't add fuel to the fire soft
assume the best inch'allah till next
semester i'm alaikum wa rahmatu America